et maintenant on pense tout plein
j'appelle manche qui a vu peu ventées
des couleurs
bonne année
gary d'angoulême hantise de qu'on soit
là
bonsoir
ils pensaient qu'ils quartier qui est
résident dj résident dans cette émission
et résidents sortie résidents corses y
résident dans camion qui est sa une fois
je suis allé en prison ou en résidence
pas bien ouais 11 ans qu'en voyant pas
des collègues ce n'est pas déconner il
était à lire la sortie à la chanter dans
wii fit wii spécial crooner spécial
preneur mais les crooners ça vient
jamais tout seul tu as des gonzesses
yade à il ya deux blonde une brune un
spécial bar crooner américain
gbagbo
au téléthon alors bon soir et j'ai des
blondes et brunes bien alors et la
boutique jamais vulgaire j'en ai fait
des siennes principes tels que
connaissait le principe donc au départ
en joue par équipe l'équipe des garçons
comme trop l'équipe des filles
voilà vous avez explosé il va être
difficile damien carême vous explosez
est alors le blind test c'est un spécial
crooner voilà un oui voilà qui est tué
près par grave chute bébé
m
c'est là bas
oh
jamais
dans ce sens même si son peuple
ça c'est bien de braguette et gonzesses
maintenant je fais ça tu dois je suis
désolé c'est la première fois que je
faisais je sais mais bon donc scellé
baffie qui m'a
oh non
moi
non bien non plus
attention
mais
et
oh
non
catherine catherine bois baffie 1
catherine fois bâti
on n'a pas la taille et en image par
image narrant catherine baba fille
catherine vois ma fille catherine voix
basse et les migrations
garçons quoi ya quelques mois mais
c'était en secret et là qu'il a fait une
bourde
c'est dommage pour philippe bien donc un
point pour les garçons corty
le nom de gérard darmon plein de monde
donc ça fait deux points pour les
garçons zéro point pour les filles
précisions c'est ici
salut tu m'a engueulé précision
chirurgicale après ouais c'est vrai
il
les armes
la montagne ou non mais
robin
suivant les filles
valérie l'avant
j nicole kidman et robbie williams bravo
bravo rachida donc vous relever
l'honneur des filles vous marquez un
point vraiment attention au ce on se
concentre pascal on se concentre fini on
peut dire qu'il avait une fille célèbre
aussi oui parce qu'ils ont c'est
difficile
celui qui vient ouais ouais c'est vrai
eric peugeot sport qu'on met en commun
pas il a trouvé le temps que nous
écrivons robert
beaucoup d'hôtels classés we prochain
son copain
moi
ouais mais oui mais catherine qu'est ce
que tu veux que tu dis je les trouve
trop vite parce qu'il est très fort
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dis mais
on laisse les auquel l'avion mais un
bout de dean martin pour catherine ça
c'est de lui rappeler un truc sexuelle
s'il est prouvé une fois de plus vous
pourrez danser
bien sûr il a alors il ya des fissures
mais c'est génial soyez qui dit vas-y
corti ces partis en mission
m
bryan ferry brown yes michaud corti mr
bravo à celle là je vous attends
attention à temps
ah oui
il est revenu seul dans laquelle il ya
pas longtemps en régie l'ont trouvé
non
m
c'est important car chaque membre
ouais ouais
comme j'aime
dring dring
non
bravo et si chauffe pas prêt ce blind
test à la maison c'est donc ça fait 4
pour les garçons 3 pour les filles les
prix remonte cortier roulement la marge
en imap jean louis
casting
avoir gagné
à 100 quand daniel auteuil pour toi
thouaré
destiné
m
qu'est-ce-qui
ah oui oui c'est dur hein attention là
c'est très dur il ya que dany et
bruckner qui peuvent trouver à mon avis
sur philippe rey
bravo les filles sont à 4 ouais bravo
l'agent sable on peut écouter un peu un
jean sablon jean sablon c'est le premier
mec jean sablon chanter avec un micro et
à l'époque tout le monde disait que
c'était un scandale de chanter avec un
micro jean sablon soutenir le révérend
vous qui passez sans me voir jean sablon
bah oui c'est bien qu'ils donnent à jean
sablon des dons on a beaucoup
d'affinités quand même hein ça peut
arriver là ce soir je sens que 1
ouais je sens que la ja mais vas-y
philippe la suite
oh moi
tu es un
la france donne car les chevaux jal sur
l'histoire mais en quatre chevaux
charges ont tiré la carte
ouais mais line alors mes lignes tu fais
tirer une carte à à marilou berry
marilou c'est ta soirée
qu'est ce tu cherches tu me cherches la
tireuse de cartes esquire mathieu
lagarde anne marie engagement direct
parce que le coupé au montage qui ont
été enregistrées voilà on a les marines
devait me donner l'interprète du morceau
vous allez entendre à ses biens dont on
va le faire tout de suite
un bravo bon on continue je n'y avais
pas trop attention
ouais
oui
les
non
pour jamel pour jamel remettons un petit
bout juste
et
demain
les
dans ma faim
bien alors maintenant oui les garçons
sont à 6 les filles sont à cinq noms
dont celui qui va trouver ou celle qui
va trop bien évidemment ça va équilibrer
ou pas voilà donc là c'est vraiment jeu
des pronostics thierry francis et les
filles qui vont trouver un hachoir
égaliserait mais quelques charbon mais
garde sa fiche tu penses que c'est qui
qui va prouver
je pense que agnès peut trouver oui
attention on est à 6 6 ah mais c'est
mieux que ce que je dis on est sisi donc
maintenant celui ou celle qui répond
fait gagner son équipe
c'est vachement un barrage balle de
match laurent voilà alors zik orties
c'est parti
non l'italien wind
voilà
gonflé en même temps d'essayer il faut
savoir dire que c'est les filles qui ont
gagné 7 pour les filles si ce voyage
sont pas
il faut savoir contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur
et maintenant les hyper dur ah non je
crois que c'était fini
maintenant il ya maintenant il ya le
super banco la choisissez les filles qui
ont gagné c'est l'équipe en forme alors
on sort du par équipes c'est chacun pour
sa gueule donc effectivement il ya plus
de filles que de garçons plus d'amis la
voilà celui ou celle qui trouvent ça et
star de la soirée istres est très très
difficile
dany fouille dans sa mémoire les
derniers en elle-même un bordel dedans
allons-y
philippe très dur la chanson est connue
mais
c'est très dur à trouver
j'ai donné les indices et en anglais non
c'est pas robert ballmer c'est un
anglais je réponds à serge c'est un
anglais qui a un nom un peu zarbi qui
était le concurrent de tom jones
à l'époque sur vingeanne et 66 67 de
quel signe à un copieur c'est la mesure
qui peut demain je pense qu'on peut
donner le prénom remet un peu la musique
son nom commence son nom de famille
commence par un h
dur
on reconnaîtra
thomas a
non c'est en allemand qui commence par h
mais ce n'est pas inné n'avaient pas
leurs noms n'ont personne c'est trop
c'est hyper isabelle syrie à trouver
alors isabelle abbas est possible
isabelle qui s'est engueulé berthe un
piercing boys
et
à
eon gagnait temps
grand beau dépit bordeaux agnès ça fait
marcher la gueule de le dire bien ce que
je voulais vous dire c'est que je vienne
prochaine ya pas tout le monde en parle
parce que la vie est âgé il faut que
c'est parce que je suis à megève normal
je m'occupe des régimes d'héroïne
non ya pas de tout le monde en parle
dans ce cas une émission sur la chanson
française sur france 2 qui va durer de
20h50 3 heures du matin donc apparemment
pas et on va là donc voilà donc rendez
vous le 22 janvier voilà merci c'était
une aubaine et sa dame de saman abdul
majeed george owino mission chez nous
chez fayard géant de villiers au cache
la vérité c'est chez fayard et ça sort
le 12 janvier bernard kouchner remercie
bernard barraqué avec lui ce soir daniel
auteuil berri l'un reste l'autre part de
groupes et avec charlotte gainsbourg
nathalie
miou-miou le 12 janvier plus la bande
originale du film à anne parillaud terre
promise d'amos gitaï
sortie le 12 janvier christophe
hondelatte faites entrer l'accusé l'un
josacine empoisonnée le temps s'arrête
chez michel lafon
le 13 janvier marilou berry cas ni
rachida brakni les monologues du vagin à
19 heures on peut tout faire de paris et
le dimanche à 17h dimanche pascal
bruckner l'amour du prochain merci
pascal chez grasset agnès michaux d
hymne à la merci aux éditions du rocher
brent est fils corti alors ya un livre
que je vois que tu montes quelques et
karine qui nous a inspiré le qui nous a
inspiré le blind thèse c'est crooner de
jean baptiste cuse et voilà c'est un
très beau livre qu'il faut absolument
acheter il nous a inspiré ce blind test
et la compil est bien aussi voilà jean
baptiste say
merci
des rendez vous le 22 janvier je dis
bien le vote d'aujourd'hui